SECOND HALF OF A BACK TO  34 GA.
ANDNET.
THAT IS DOBSON.
THE CORNER, DIDN'T GET A LOT OF
STICK ON  POWER PLAY GOAL IN
THREE  THE NET.
THAT IS KULIKOV.
HIT THE BOARDS SO HARD THE GOA
BACKWARDS.
AND
LO
HERE TONIGHT.
HE WILL COME OUT, TO NELSON, HE
SCORES! BLOCKED BY THECHECK, THS
ONE IS ON STURGEON.
NT OF HIM.
HE
RASK, HE BEEN DEFLECTED.
NO CHANCE FOR  TURNED IT OVER,
ISLANDERS.
S HAD TO MAKEGOAL.
EIGHT CAREER GOALS IN 96 THE BE.
DO
OVER FOR WRIST SHOT.
>> Butch: LOOKING FOR A BOUNCE
OFF THE SHORT SIDE.
>> Brendan: A SWING AND A SIDE.
GOOD PLAY INSIDE THE BLUE LINE
BY BROCK  CHARA.
MATHEW  THEY SCORE. A DEFLECTIO.
PART OF THAT
>> Butch: WORKINGING HARD ON HIS
MATHEW BARZAL, SAVE MADE.
FREE, THEY SCORE!
AND DIVING TOWARD THE
SOROKIP, BREAKING TO THE  DOBSO.
AM TO THE FRONT OF THE NET FOR
IT IN.
THE ISLES TAP IT AROUN